i think for you music comes so easily
is it true that you wrote when i'm 64
when you were 15 years old
on a piano yeah we had a piano in the
house so i wrote the tune i didn't write
the words those came later
but i had to do that were you considered
a prodigy i mean when you sit down right
when i'm
you were not no way nobody was remotely
interested in this idea of
i wrote songs until i met john i said
i've written a few songs
and he said oh so have i so it was like
amazing someone was interested at last
and i'd seen him around liverpool he'd
got on a bus
once and i said whoa look at this guy
at the big side boards you know the hair
swept back
i thought he's got something going don't
look yeah i
definitely had a look and so when i met
him it was great i was looking up
to him i wasn't that impressed because
he smelled of beer
and i was a little bit younger and i
wasn't too keen on this big smelly
breath
leaning over me but uh we got together
and they wanted me in the band
so i finally know i said well let me
think about it i'll get back to you on
that
i didn't immediately just go yeah really
yeah i was on my bike i was cycling
along
up near john's area and his friend
pete came down and he said hey wait a
minute wait a minute he said they want
you to join
the band can i tell them yeah i said
well
i don't know let me think about it you
know you built it so i took it took
about a week
i'm busy doing nothing right so i took
about a week and then got back to i said
yeah okay
i'll do that what was your hesitation
why wouldn't you join the quarry man i
mean this this is
you know i'm like that i'm not i'm not i
don't rush into things
i think i'm allowed to have a minute to
think about it
because wait a minute you know i do i
want to be in a band
i'd never been in a band do i want to be
in this band
and then i decided yeah you know we
could do something with this band